we're we're here as I said at Labor
Party conference we're now joined by the
shadow health secretary John Ashworth
thank you very much for being with us a
bright and early this morning good
morning now you've got a new policy out
haven't you what is it that you want to
do well I've been looking at the way in
which prescriptions are delivered in
England and actually prescriptions are
now free in Scotland they're free in
Wales the free in Northern Ireland so I
think the people of England need the
same deal I think it will be fair to
abolish prescription charges now in
England as well and that's what I'm
announcing today at the Labour Party
conference so how much would this cost
and how would you pay for it well we've
we've allocated in our in our plans
around 745 million pounds for it and
actually when we get closer to the
general election will outline our full
financial plans for the NHS but you know
politics about choices right and this is
a government that has chosen to give
away billions in tax cuts to the very
wealthiest of estates through in a big
inheritance tax cuts and billions and in
tax cuts in cooperation tax and actually
yes there is a cost to this but when
you've got a situation we have a third
of people because they cannot afford
their prescriptions we're not picking
them up a third of people with arthritis
are not picking up their prescriptions
because they can't afford it when you've
got a situation where people live with
asthma forgoing inhalers it was a
heartbreaking story of a young woman of
19 who died because she couldn't afford
her inhaler for asthma I think
abolishing prescription charges is the
first thing to do they do in Scotland
they do it in Wales I don't understand
while the Tory government isn't giving
the English people the same deal that
people of Wales and Scotland are no
minute because everyone would like free
prescriptions I wouldn't pay for it well
we are gonna outline our tax and
spending they don't know yet no we well
we are we are working we are working on
these and John McDonough will come
forward like he did at the last general
election will the only party the last
general election they've produced a
detailed costings plan of each and every
policy this is you're announcing and you
haven't worked out how you can fund that
the next general election John MacDonald
will outline an itemized spending plan
for each and every policy in the same
way he did at the last general election
but by the way there is a there is a
immediate cost to this but you've got a
situation now
where people are not taking their
medicines and are gettin iller and that
puts more pressure on the NHS oh you've
got a situation where people are not
getting their medicine cuz they can't
afford a prescription and they're taking
more time off work affecting
productivity in the economy and
affecting the our overall economic
growth so actually this is a sensible
intervention but for the NHS for
people's health but for the economy as a
whole I want to ask you about another
policy that Labour are pushing today
about scrapping Ofsted the schools
inspectors I mean I can imagine this
it's gonna go down very well with
teachers a lot of parents will be like
worried to hear that but we want to
drive up standards in schools that is
absolutely key I'm I'm a parent of their
two little girls we were at my local
local primary school state schools by
the way and I don't use private schools
I send my kids to state schools I went
to a comprehensive as a working class
black and I'm proud to have gone to a
comprehensive and my priority has indeed
is Angela rayna's and everybody at least
labor conference is to drive up
standards in every single state school
and yes we don't think the obstetric
gene works anymore but we're still gonna
have an inspector of schools because I'm
driving up those I've got a few
questions about this policy I will admit
and so the idea that I've read in the
papers this morning is that local
councils will run regular health checks
and then schools will only get more
fuller inspectors by full-time trained
professionals if something is quite up
so so let's all do a million spectra
then but the Constitution is something
to be inspected if it's councils is this
gonna be political how do you stand it
politically standardised some
inspections across a hundred quarters
having council area how do parents know
that this is some time in London
I mean local authority team local
authorities carry out all kinds of
important functions which are not
politicized but held to account but
democratically by counts what matters
but local authorities do all kinds of
things they responsible for children's
children's social care they're
responsible for Public Health functions
nobody thinks they are politicized
Howdy's decisions well there's going to
be another Inspectorate as well is going
to be a but it's not going to tell you
something it's not gonna be as
heavy-handed and as simplistic as what
we've got with us there but I don't but
I wouldn't want your viewers to be to
misunderstand our schools are still
going to be inspected and we're still
going to be driving up standards
schools it also starts by the way with
properly funding a schools not cutting a
primary schools in the poorest areas
like he's happening in might less the
South constituency where the richer
areas are getting they're better that
financial settlement giving schools fair
funding investing in staff so we've got
the very best teachers educating our
schools because putting children first
is one of our priorities you were
talking a bit earlier about your
comprehensive school background we know
that conference is going to be debating
the idea of abolishing private schools
is that something you'd support well it
will see where the debate gets to and I
think Angela rain is going to be talking
about it well I think the tax loopholes
that some of these drivers are taking
advantage of tax loopholes and that's
what we need to do sure wait should they
be abolished well you know I've never
liked her
I've never liked primary school a
private school I look the primary skills
that was a bit of a slip wasn't it
they'll be all having a go at me on
Twitter now no private schools
I've never liked private schools at all
and I think they do need to be reformed
Donna I'm a big fan of Tony Crossland
who was very very rude about the the
private school system but we'll see
whether we'll see what the confidence
decides but the priority has got to be
standards in our state schools for the
many for the majority of children and in
this school in this country go to state
schools and it's driving up standards
and giving them the very best quality of
education now we've been talking about
policy so far are you worried that these
policy discussions are going to be
overshadowed by more internal labor
party trouser and we've seen the aborted
attempt to get rid of Tom Watson for
example dominating the coverage of come
I mean I you know whatever people think
of Tom Watson and he's you know he's got
supporters and he's got people who are
not so keen on him in the Labor Party I
mean I thought getting rid of the office
of deputy leader of the Labor Party was
counterproductive misguided it it's a
position that we've had for seventy
years held by night Bevin Michael foot
Dennis Ely you know I think everybody
knows I was a bit frustrated yesterday
when
announcement about training 5000 GPS so
we have 27 million extra GP appointments
that's what a Labour government's going
to deliver that's what I announced
yesterday so I was a bit frustrated yes
that had been overshadowed but look that
was yesterday the NEC are not putting
that forward and today tomorrow and
Tuesday and Wednesday we're going to be
focusing on our policies for government
and I know that's what you want to do
but more questions about this because
some people will be looking at this and
think is it really credible that this
was all just down to John Landsman and
Jeremy Corbyn didn't know anything about
it at all come on he was either ignorant
of what his closest allies were doing oh
he knew he was put forward by John
Landsman and I've known John years your
viewers probably got a clue who John
Landsman is by the way but I've known
him for years and I've been coming to
this conference now since since my first
conference in 1996 I've been come to
this conference for a long time and I've
known John Smith and have had all kinds
of conference discussions and so on this
is John John Landsman is a master of all
the different maneuvers at conference so
but look it's it's off the table now
it's gone it's not focusing on is it
credible that Jeremy Corbyn had no idea
that this was gonna happen
what John bondsmen John Landsman does
what John Landsman wants to do and he
put it forward at the NEC as far as I'm
aware I mean I don't know he's honest
answer I got no idea what discussions
are good I'm not on the NEC anymore but
look it's gone now that is gone you know
so why we don't need to obsess about
that anymore
we need to focus on the policies like
more GPS more GP appointments getting
rid of prescriptions as we hold on I'm
Andrew Fisher
yeah one of jeremy corbyn's longer
standing age the man who was responsible
for the successful and working member
has decided that he's gonna stand down
now in the sunday time into the Sunday
Times they report a memo that he sent
where he says the leaders team have a
lack of professionalism competence and
human decency he's sick of the blizzard
of Lies in explain I think he's put out
a statement saying he's you know he's
worked there for four years it's a it's
hard work stressful I in the previous
life I used to work for a leader of the
Labour Party in one of these backroom
jobs they are hard work and he wants to
move on towards the end of the year to
spend more time with his young family
being due to firmly commitment I've not
seen that memo but I've been working
hard with Andrew Fisher on our policies
like our extra GPS like our extra GP
appointments and like our three
prescriptions policy and I thought well
I didn't know Andrew Fisher for four
years ago I'd read all the stuff on the
you know the you know the you know the
Twitter and all that but in the four
years I've worked with with him I found
him
professional diligent and as I say I've
worked closely with him in the last few
days and developing and our policies to
recruit my GPS and abolish prescription
charges now keen to ask you about brexit
well we've got us fowl and the Labour
Party now supports a second referendum
in all circumstances but it hasn't said
how it would campaign in that referendum
would you campaign for leave or remain
well I'm a remainer and my constituency
voted remain and many of my constituents
who want us to remain but I actually
think the policy we've put forward is
has merit and logic because we've got to
understand that we we as a Labour Party
speak out for those constituencies like
mine who are labour voters and remain
voters but we also speak out our speak
up for the constituencies like Ashfield
like Doncaster like vans Lee who voted
leave but are also Labour voters so
we've got to unite the country and I
think that's an entirely respectable
thing to do the key thing is this right
you know you've got the Liberal leader
saying that we should just sort of end
you know and Bret I mean the Liberal
Party were the first ones calling for a
referendum by the way you know we're in
this mess because they were pandering
I'm calling for a referendum you know
five or six years ago but actually the
party now offering a referendum is the
Labour Party so if your viewers want a
referendum they should vote Labour in
this upcoming election I mean Jeremy
Corbyn has not really said how he would
campaign but you get the sense he wants
to try and remain as neutral as possible
is that really credible issue that is so
polarizing that is the number one
divisive issue under Boris Johnson you
know exactly the Conservative Party
stand on the Lib Dems you know exactly
why that's poor you don't know where
Boris Johnson's lies all over the place
there is there at Rondo no labour slips
through the pizza you know
you know partner that parts of the
country want to leave parts the country
wants to remain right what we are trying
to do is bring people together and say
to people we will negotiate a brexit
deal a one by one which tries to
safeguard jobs that doesn't have the
huge nets and shortages which Boris
Johnson steel would inevitably entail
but it's also saying to those
constituents like mine in Leicester that
if you don't support reps it and you
want to remain that option will be on
the ballot paper as well as I say I
think that position has merits and logic
and I'm totally relaxed about it so
similar similar positions which Hamill
Wilson adopted in the in the mid 70s and
it worked for Howell Wilson so um you
know it's fine by but why are you doing
better in the person well you know
they're new new governments coming in
always have a bit of a bounce but look
you know we've got to work harder have a
way we've got to work harder and that's
why this conference is what I'm actually
focusing on issues which matter the
people it matters but if your child is
ill and you're trying to get a GP
appointment you're there like ringing
pressing redial and redial and read
Allah when they get an appointment it's
not for weeks I mean what good is that
and I'm at Hancock says oh don't worry
we're gonna force them to give you GP
appointments or find the GPS ain't gonna
work we need more GPS these are the
issues were talking about this week
we're out of time thank you very much
for being on the program thank you